l'avis de bonjour alors le vaccin contre
le coc u19 d'astrazeneca et toujours
soutenue par plusieurs pays occidentaux
malgré sa suspension en afrique du sud
un son efficacité est de plus en plus
contestée contre le variant sud
africains notamment
alors quel est le problème et bien c'est
d'abord l'origine du virus qui est le
principal problème à l'efficacité du
vaccin anglo suédois astrazeneca contre
le variant sud africain appelé b 1351
elles sont rentrées dans les termes
techniques et pour bien comprendre il
faut s'intéresser aux premiers patients
atteints de ce variant en cause leur
système immunitaire ce qu'on appelle des
patients immunodéprimés
c'est ce qu'ils ont du poil qui ont dû
plus de mal à supprimer les infections
c'est ce que déclare les spécialistes et
si ce qui pourrait expliquer que le
virus se reproduit beaucoup plus chez
ces patients et se transmet plus
facilement
est ce qui explique également la faible
efficacité du vaccin astrazeneca au
contraire de pfizer green tech et
moderna je vous propose d'écouter à ce
sujet le président sud africain a du
comité des vaccins malheureusement quand
le vaccin administré a été analysé le
taux d'efficacité est descendu à 20% 22%
c'est vraiment très bas et évidemment
éthiquement nous ne pouvons pas vraiment
utiliser un vaccin qui aura un si faible
degré d'efficacité
donc la décision a été prise de
suspendre purement et simplement
l'utilisation du vaccin astrazeneca pour
le moment jusqu'à ce que nous soyons
certain de son efficacité
jusqu'à ce que nous obtenions plus de
données ce vaccin pourrait bien et c'est
vraiment une spéculation être efficace
pour se protéger contre une forme d'
infections graves et une hospitalisation
et nous étudions vraiment cette
hypothèse sur d'autres vax en parallèle
donc le vaccin d'astrazeneca est
toujours à l'étude
mais pour le moment nous avons suspendu
son utilisation et avons décidé le
déploiement d'autres vaccins voilà vous
l'aurez compris on pointe surtout du
doigt les formes graves de ce variant et
surtout une possible réfection art
feed l'exemple est assez frappant
lorsque le variant sud africain a été
découvert en octobre le pays recensait
environ 2000 cas de contamination par
jour à la mi janvier on en recense près
de vingt mille nouveaux cas quotidiens
le variant représente près de 90 % des
infections en france pour le moment on
estime entre 1 et 2%
mais on s'interroge aussi sur
l'efficacité du vaccin autorisé la
semaine dernière par la haute autorité
de santé
et pourtant la venue d'olivier véran
persiste et signe avec ce vaccin
le ministre de la santé souhaite
rassurer avant tout oui pour une seule
bonne raison les vielles il va faciliter
la vaccination de masse puisqu'il est
plus simple à transporter à stocker et
donc moins coûteux c'est en partie pour
cela qu'on peut dire que lui et veyran
qui a reçu une première injection de ce
vaccin a voulu rassurer et ce qui
inquiète réellement les spécialistes
français c'est la crainte immédiate pour
les soignants puisque je le rappelle il
devrait leur être administrés
l'interrogation se posent sur le fait
que le vaste le vaccin astrazeneca ne
soit pas assez efficace pour éviter les
contaminations à l'hôpital et multiplie
donc les clusters les syndicats à deux
soignants sont déjà montés au créneau
sur twitter regarder au vu de la
décision de l'afrique du sud suspendre
ces vaccinations avec astrazeneca du
fait d'une possible inefficacité sur
variant sud africain une flm communauté
demandent que les soignants exposés aux
qu'ovide 19 dans leur exercice
bénéficient des vaccins n'est plus
protecteurs les vaccins les plus
protecteurs car les soignants sont
exposés à une charge virale plus
importante que la population est donc
plus de risque d'être contaminé
conséquent si le vaccin qu'il aurait
injecté est moins efficace de nombreux
soignants seront malades et les hôpitaux
seront vite débordé sans personnel at
une étude parue dans la revue médicale
nature affirme que le vaccin à pfizer
biotech et plus efficace et plus
efficace contre le variant sud africain
en tout cas il réduirait la transmission
du virus à l'idée pour les spécialistes
et donc d'optimiser les vaccins afin de
protéger au mieux la population et de
maîtriser l'épidémie au cas où le var
sud africains se propagerait en france
une inquiétude de laquelle pour le
moment le ministre de la santé n'a pas
répondu
merci beaucoup david pour toutes ces
précisions david khalifa en direct
devant le ministère de la santé à paris